so I'm gonna talk to you today about a
different way of looking at what real is
it's not easy to figure out what real is
because we don't really have internet
knowledge and so we're always making
some sets of presuppositions about
what's most real and it really matters
what you assume is most real because you
base the decisions that you make that
run the entire course of your life on
those assumptions whether you recognize
it or not and if you get the assumptions
wrong or even if you leave them
incomplete you're gonna pay a big price
for it and the assumptions that we use
in our culture although they've enabled
us to develop a tremendously potent
technology are incomplete in ways that
have also cost us and that are extremely
dangerous
since the scientific age began we've
lived in a universe where the bottom
strata of reality is considered to be
something that's dead like dirt it's
like it's matter its objective its
external and there isn't any element of
it that lends any reality to phenomena
like meaning or purpose that's all being
relegated to the subjective and in some
ways to the illusory but it's by no
means self-evident that that set of
presuppositions is correct because we
lacked infinite knowledge and there's
many things about the structure of being
that we don't understand the main one
being consciousness we can't account for
it at all and we can't account for the
role it appears to play in the
transformation of potential into
actuality which is a role that's been
recognized by physicists for almost a
hundred years now and which remains one
of the biggest unsolved
in science there are other ways of
looking at what's real and these other
ways have some advantages and one of the
advantages they have is that they
protect us knowing these other ways of
operating within reality defining
reality protect us from certain kinds of
pathologies and modern people are prone
to a fair number of pathologies that
stem from the assumptions of their of
their of the systems they use to define
reality and one of those pathologies is
a kind of a nihilistic hopelessness
which is a consequence of the
recognition that in the final analysis
nothing really has any meaning and
because life is difficult and that's a
meaning that you can't escape being
forced to abandon your belief in a
positive or a transcendent meaning can
leave you weak the times when you really
can least afford to be weak and there's
more important pathologies that it's
opened us up to - and those are
pathologies of belief and I think we saw
the most horrifying examples of that
hopefully the most horrifying examples
in the 20th century where people whose
belief systems were shattered at least
in part by the competition between
religious and scientific viewpoints
turned in large numbers to mass
movements that were in error in every
way a substitute a more rational in some
sense substitute for religious beliefs
that appeared no longer tenable and the
consequence of that was it was just
about annihilation because we came close
to annihilation twice once in the 60s
and once in the 80s and even without the
totality of annihilation we lost
hundreds of millions of people as a
consequence of pathological belief
systems in the 20th century
so if belief systems become pathological
they put that pathology can pose as the
biggest threat possibly to our very
existence and if you're a Darwinian in
any sense you have to understand that
the things that pose the biggest threats
to your survival are the most real
things they have to be dealt with now
here's another way of looking at things
I'll start with the definition of this
word this word famous thigh is the root
word of phenomena phenomenon and
phenomena are
things that appear to you and famous
thymines to shine forth and the
phenomenologist hsihu were interested in
the shining forth of things made the
presumption that the things that
manifested themselves to you as most
meaningful were the most real things and
I think you can make a strong case that
that's actually how your brain is wired
because your brain is wired to react to
things that have meaning before they
construct the perceptions that you think
of as objects and the reason for that is
because the meaning of things is more
real in some sense but more important
than the view of things as objects and
so for example a famous philosopher
psychologist a vision said that when you
approach a cliff you don't see a cliff
you see a falling off place it isn't
that it's an object cliff to which you
attribute the meaning of falling off
place - it's the falling off place
perception comes first and the
abstraction of the object of cliff if it
ever happens it all comes much later
much later conceptually because even
babies can detect cliffs and much later
historically poets have noticed this
phenomena shining forth reality and
they've often associated with childhood
and I think there's good reasons for
that I think your brain is not so much
of an inhibitory structure when you're a
child before it's fully developed and so
there's there's neurological reasons for
noting it but there's also reasons that
stem from the level of lived experience
you can tell when you're around children
that they're open to things in a way
that adults aren't they're wide eyed
with wonder and adults like being around
children for that reason because
although the child takes an awful lot of
care and is a terrifying object in some
ways to behold if you have a
relationship with the child because
they're so vulnerable the part of the
way they pay you back is they open up
your eyes your eyes that have been
closed by your experience and that have
learned to shield out the things that
shine forth and when you have a child
you can look through the child's eyes
again and to me it's like they're on
fire in a sense they're like a candle or
something that's burning brightly and I
think that's also partly because we
actually don't screen out fire we
actually see fire and that's why we
can't not look at it when it's around I
think the same thing
happens when you're in love with someone
if it's if it's genuine love because
genuine love gives you a hint of what
could be in the future if you could just
set yourself right you get a glimpse of
what could be in the future if you fall
in love with someone you don't get that
without work but you get a glimpse of it
and I think it's because when you fall
in love and I believe this is likely a
biochemical transformation is the
perceptual structures that normally stop
you from seeing people because you
really don't see people you just see
shadows they did that the the the
barriers are lifted temporarily and
what's really there shines through and
it's overwhelming but to stay in that
state well it requires a tremendous
amount of moral effort is really the
right way of thinking about it
Wordsworth said about children and there
was a time when meadow Grove and stream
the earth and every common sight to me
did seem apparelled in celestial light
the glory and the freshness of a dream
it is not now as it hath been of your
turn where so ever I may buy neither day
the things which I have seen I now can
see no more earth fills her lap with
pleasures of her own yearnings she hath
in her own natural kind and even with
something of a mother's mind and no
unworthy aim the homely nurse doth all
she can to make her foster child her
inmate man forget the glories he hath
known and that Imperial parents palace
whence he came and what Woodsworth means
by this is that as you develop as an as
a competent adult which which is
precisely the direction towards which
you should develop much of what you're
doing is actually closing in and
narrowing you're closing in and
narrowing towards a particular goal in a
particular way of being and that's
necessary because as you develop you
have to develop towards a particular way
of being or you don't develop at all and
you can stay a child forever that goes
that goes sour of its own accord and so
human beings are destined to close their
perceptions in to sharpen themselves and
to focus on very little so that they can
at least do
that but the price we pay for that is
that we start to replace the
relationship we have with untrammeled
reality with the shadows that are only
complex enough to let us do what we need
to do and no more and in some sense
although we become more competent in
other ways we've become more blind and
we kind of know how this happens that
happens from the bottom up now this is a
Magritte painting and the painting has
an obvious meaning in a sense which is
that we're blinded even to what's right
in front of us by the objects that we
see and we think that seeing is letting
in the light but it's only letting in a
very small fraction of the light because
we're only capable of contemplating a
small fraction of everything whenever
we're doing any particular thing and so
very much of what we're doing is
screening things out very much of your
cortex is inhibitory and Magritte is
trying to get at that with that idea
it's like there's a businessman there
he's dressed in his uniform you can't
see beyond the immediate the immediate
thing that's in front of his eyes how
does that happen well let's say you're a
baby he the first thing you learn you
learn you build your body from the
bottom up you build your perceptual and
action structures from the bottom up you
Lou to move your arm you learn to close
your hand then you learn to do things
that are practical with those abilities
you lift the spoon well you have to do
that to feed yourself you learn to move
a plate you learn to set the table
that's starting to become social now
because you can set the table for you
and for other people you learn to make a
meal that's a more complex sequencing of
motor activities and perceptual
abilities that's very focused as you
continue to develop the things you chain
together become more and more complex
and and but also more specific you you
have to care for your family which means
there's all sorts of other things you're
not doing you have to find a good job
which almost everyone when they're young
experiences as the contemplation of a
limitation well not everyone but many
people think oh no you know I'm going to
have to settle for this role I don't
want to only be that rule but it's
better to be that rule that no role at
all and maybe the way through the role
to the other side is through the role
don't around it there's no avoiding the
responsibilities of narrow
growing and shaping and specializing be
a good parent well that's the sacrifice
you make for the next generation be a
good partner the same thing be a good
citizen what's easy for young people in
particular to be skeptical of that
because the old society is always
corrupt in archaic and blind and to
become a member of that seems to be in
part to to allow yourself to adopt that
same age blindness but that thing also
educates you it shapes every word you
speak it's something that you have to be
grateful to even in its age of the
archaic form and it's part of the nest
success ''tis of human responsibility
that you become a good citizen and that
means in some sense giving up more of
what could be at least to sustain what
is there's a satirical song from the
late 1890s English I am the very model
of a modern major-general I've
information vegetable animal and mineral
I know the kings of England and I quote
the fights historical from marathon to
Waterloo in order categorical and the
satire is well he has the knowledge he's
an official functionary and it's very
difficult to do that but in the same way
it's very limited in categorical and of
course an artist would object to that
but it's better than nothing at all and
that's the alternative well above that
maybe what's above good citizen because
sometimes good citizen is not so good if
you were a good citizen of Nazi Germany
or a good citizen of the Soviet Union or
of Mao's China you know you were
narrowed in a particular way but and
then maybe in a necessary way but also
in a very pathological way and so it
seems to be that there has to be
something even though adopting that
restricted viewpoint is necessary there
has to be something above it and I think
that's also the thing that can restore
the sense you have of a true
entanglement with the the deepest and
most meaningful realities of life and
that's the issue of being a good person
it's above being a citizen it's
something else it has something to do
with the development of individuality
and I think we're all so wired for the
so it looks like we're wired to lose
what we had to specialize but then once
we're specialized to reopen but once
we've got the skills built into our body
and then can hand handle reality because
we're more adapted and more fluid and
more flexible then we can start opening
the doors again and I and I believe that
your nervous system is set up to help
you do that if you don't interfere with
it if you notice and you notice that by
paying attention to the things that
manifest themselves to you that shine
forth as interesting they grab you and
where you're grabbed is where the
obscuring map you live in isn't
obscuring the reality that's underneath
it's like there's a hole in the map and
the light shines through that and you're
attracted to that and that will pull you
along and that's when your interest is
seized by something that's your nervous
system doing that you don't do that it's
it's an unconscious force you could even
say it was the world itself talking to
you and the phenomenologist didn't feel
that way and it's a real phenomena it's
not a secondary thing and you know that
because you can't live without it you
die is stultify you get cynical you get
nihilistic or you adopt some wild belief
system if you don't have the attachment
to some genuine life-giving meaning in
your own life and it's a hard thing to
follow that because it doesn't
necessarily put you into perfect
juxtaposition with society because it's
not society it's not being a good
citizen it's something else it's also
the thing that rebuilds how you would be
a good citizen
the Egyptians knew about this a long
time ago they didn't really know they
knew because they acted things out in
drama and portrayed them mythologically
because they didn't have the capacity to
articulate the ideas fully but the
Egyptians worshiped the human eye and
they worshiped the eye because they knew
the eye was the thing that paid
attention like we're really visual
creatures and your eye is automatically
attracted to the things that manifest
themselves or shine forth in front of
you and you have to look at them if you
pay attention to the things that shine
forth because what you're seeing is the
reality instead of the map you're
gaining access to the real information
that's in the world it's not prepackaged
in for me
because that can be false it's the real
information flowing out from the ground
of being and if you pay attention to
that it will help you move towards the
goals that you've already established
for yourself as a good citizen that are
part of the inbuilt value structure that
you've adopted but at the same time it
will do something else
it will lead you to transform the nature
of those goals because as you pursue the
thing that guides your interest and more
and more information is revealed then by
absorbing that information which is
learning essentially you build yourself
into a different person a stronger and
more informed person and at a more a
more intact person a person with more
integrity and with more strength than
with more direction and at the same time
you differentiate your map and so you're
living more and more in the real world
so as you approach your specific goal
even if it's a culturally conditioned
goal the learning that you do along the
way transforms you and it transforms the
nature of your goal things shine forth
and there's a reason for that and you
know that because when you're attending
to something you're interested in and
you're engaged it that's when you're
alive that's when life is worthwhile
it's so worthwhile that in those moments
you don't even ask the question about it
the question itself goes away because
the meaning that your Lea United with is
so powerful that it can push back the
adversity that would otherwise
characterize life Nietzsche said the
person who has a Y can bear any how and
and that's a really useful thing to know
because you think well we're very
vulnerable creatures in our life and
catastrophic ly and and terrible things
happen and how can we bear that in the
answer to that is and always has been
that you have to be in sync with
something that's beyond you because that
synchrony gives you the strength that
you need to bear your terrible
limitations you see this played out
people know this everyone knows this
it's just that our culture isn't good at
articulating it we've lost a lot of this
we haven't developed our knowledge about
this as much as we've developed our
knowledge of the objective world and
we're paying for it you see it weird
places on the on the right here there's
an old symbol at the bottom it's called
the round chaos when the alchemists
believed that the round chaos was the
thing that
held what was what the world was
ultimately made of the thing that was
most real and they conceptualized it as
something like information they thought
about it as a combination of spirit and
matter and it was a combination of
spirit and matter which is what
information is in a sense because when
you interacted with it you took some of
the information and you built yourself
out of it so that was the spiritual
element and you took some of the
information and you built the world out
of it and that was the material element
and they thought of the reality itself
is something that preceded the spiritual
in the material and that that reality
was what Shawn forth and that's been
dramatized and in entails modern tales
of transformation the most interesting
places popped up is in the Harry Potter
stories where central to the Harry
Potter theme is a game called Quidditch
and in Quidditch which is a game the way
you win the game is by playing a game
that's sort of outside the Quidditch
game you win the Quidditch game by
finding following this thing that
beckons this golden thing that glimmers
and moves around you if you catch that
then you win the game if so does your
whole team and inside that is it is the
resurrection stone it's up it's a
diamond it's a it's a jewel the idea is
that if you follow the thing that
manifests itself to you is interesting
it will lead you through adversity and
lead you to do things that are difficult
and as that happens but not beyond your
capacity because it's tempered for that
what will happen is as you hit yourself
against the world pursuing what you're
interested in you'll tap yourself into
alignment your molecules your structure
internal structure will become
noncontradictory
like the internal structure of a jewel
which is something that reflects light
that makes you hard and durable and able
to bear the terrible conditions of
existence without becoming corrupt TS
Eliot said something about this we shall
not cease from exploration and the end
of all our exploring will be to arrive
where we started and to know the place
for the first time and that's a five
line summary of the most remarkable
elaboration of the nature of the
relationship between the individual
humor
consciousness and reality itself that's
ever been penned and and and the
culmination of a system of thought
that's been developing over thousands
and thousands of years which we have
lost and cannot properly articulate
follow what you're interested in it'll
take you to over adversity and then
through it it'll transform you from a
citizen into an individual and then the
doors will open again and at that point
you're strong enough to have your life
and at that point you're strong enough
not to fall prey to pathological belief
systems and work towards the destruction
of things thank you